well you want to see how it's saying how
approaching okay okay okay i also have
med bay
do it do the thing okay
so good it's scanning confirmed he's
being scanned he's being scanned
yeah you you guys are clean right
yeah okay just making sure
what are you making sure for shouldn't
you be doing tasks
i was uh i'm really good at them uh-huh
go ahead and fix the lights hope
i don't get murdered i'm gonna fix the
lights
i hope nobody kills me
and i flick the switch why is it always
me
what's everyone else [ __ ] doing with
that time
you almost got away with it oh wow
oh holy crap okay sean
well a lot of those people were just
with you
are you really gonna flip this on me
while i stood next to you and mark
at med bay that is true
that's true i would say i saw you guys
all in
i didn't really see susie around so if
anyone could vouch for her that'd be
great
i was just doing my chores i'm the
reason you guys can breathe right now
is your chore killing people
i can't teach you i can't do chores if
i'm an imposter
that's true they're not even called
chores
[Laughter]
i can clear mark i watch him get scanned
mark is not the murderer
thank you i do feel like it's probably
not spa dicey
it's for dicey dan's all right who knows
really whoever knows that's ross and dad
i'm locking it in
give me the million dollars
dan what do you have to say for yourself
i got decontaminated a bunch of times
i don't know what function it serves but
i did it
and i feel very clean ross is the only
one who killed this fast
american atlanta cleared each other i
don't think susie and dan would kill
this one where was the body
oh it's definitely him then we got him
all right all right still one more
though mark did you vote yourself
i meant to vote for us and then you
sounded upset about it
oh man
oh gosh
dad what does that mean
[Music]
i've never pushed a button before what
happened
no no no no no i went over to do my last
wire which just so happened to be over a
hole
and then i get to the hole and what pops
out of a hole a witch's hat
followed by your body the hole was in
front of the
wire box so you admit it
oh
seems like it was probably susie but i
guess i'll never find out
guess we'll never know
who was it who was it was me and dan
did you get it right mom no no
no i don't know how nobody ever suspects
that you're teleported all the time
i told you it was down at wrong
teleporting
if only
hey what's up hi oh no
oh okay aaron okay oh all right
aaron all right
uh hey guys aaron killed susie yo whoa
what hold on
hello aaron that's done okay oh wait
hold on rebuttal aaron
yes yeah just walked up in there i was
heading to walk to reactor
he [ __ ] swiped her in half i was just
going to the telescope
yeah no and on your way you killed it
well i saw more
my my wife my beautiful wife so you just
murdered yet
former former wife why would i do that
yeah
i mean to be clear i was in the room
when it happened which was why it was so
wild that aaron did it right in front of
me oh i couldn't do it right in front of
you
i was very much there not only was it
his wife
but he wanted someone to watch don't
even
vote for yourself don't drag this out
without honor
i want to vote i'm skipping your friend
vote for the other imposter
yeah give us a tip give us a tip
oh my god get out of here
oh dear it's okay i'm around
it's dark i can't see you i'm fixing it
i'm fixing it i'm fixing it i'm fixing
it
as a matter of fact all right get me out
of here
hello hello hello
hey i'm kind of scared of you i i don't
want to be
dan what are you doing
i don't like it when you giggle dan i'm
sorry
god it's like you kill three people and
no one wants to hang out with you
anymore
i'm just trying to figure out how to
open doors why were you running away i
ran into a line
and i was adding two lights she will
attest that i didn't kill anyone wait
did that is anyone while we hung out
even though he was terrified
no i didn't dan and i were together a
bunch and nothing happened this is a
problem guys we should vote for someone
i still think it's mark oh
i'm standing with with whispered icy
just because i have nothing else to go
on
oh but if i'm wrong then we both look
stupid yeah that's true
that's super true
i guess we'll find out oh gosh
that was weak
[Applause]
hello oh oh oh that's a dead body right
here quarters or whatever
me too oh god damn it guys so close we
walked up on the body and we found
dodger there yeah
i'm gonna be honest i couldn't even what
i couldn't even
ross did you are you saying you walked
up on the body with me
no no you from the other direction you
came from the other direction i walked
up and found dodger on it
what no no we you were both i would like
to be perfectly clear that the lights
are off so
i didn't even see the body i just had to
hit report i couldn't see [ __ ] how did
you see dojo i know i walked up and i
saw the report button flicker and dodger
was standing next to it
i saw dodger also leaving and brought
like
i saw the report flash so i'm more
i would love to accuse dodger but she
has immunity we
had
i feel like i didn't see anything i just
saw a report and i know jayden was
behind me
that's it yeah i'm pretty suss of ross
and jaden right now because they're
working together pretty hard
no it wasn't jaden look at those early
votes
they entered from the right 2014.
no honor look i think it's dodgy but i
am going to skip
out of politeness and i'm also going to
say i have med bay if anyone would like
to
watch me get scanned that would be cool
we know we're [ __ ] we're good yeah yeah
look at talking talking opening the door
talking so talking doing the lights
pressing buttons all right
that's a pretty accusatory we definitely
got ross out
open the door
[Laughter]
oh okay aaron who did you vote for i
voted for hacker
clearly hacker oh yeah
listen it's not clearly hacker yes it is
your character model moved
all the jittery when you got murdered
sometimes
you know how like sometimes there's like
bugs in the system
bug snack get it yeah that's a good
rebuttal anyway you [ __ ] murdered
someone right in front of us
i did not mean to scary
i was scared of jaden the whole time
[Music]
already that's a ross play
that was quick
never gets a chance
okay what the [ __ ] happened girl why do
you keep doing this
who did it let the witch play i'm gonna
say i think
hacker didn't do it because i was one of
the first to leave keys and run away and
hackle was in my line of sight kind of
just behind me
but i could be wrong no you are
completely correct
good yes excellent i don't even know who
was in the pile i just finished my keys
and saw body
oh man for some reason i'm obsessed with
mark
i can't believe this works
i'm sorry why did i just hear you say
those idiots
uh i don't like how you guys are being
real quiet yeah
i'm sorry i'm worried about giving my
location away
i would like everyone to know that
evidence i walked past
um uh ross and i heard him say the
phrase
those idiots so i'm suspicious of that
he'd probably say that anyway that's
true
that's what i thought that is what i
thought so
uh jack and i were together and then i
stepped outside
to go up north
and saw the body
sick i mean i i did my download i'm on
my way to upload i don't know what else
to tell you
doctor what are you doing don't you
gotta kill people don't you
douga you gotta you gotta you gotta
commit crimes
you gotta commit more crimes not that i
want you to i would like
my team to win but you do have to commit
more crimes you can't just be standing
here not committing crimes
mark oh i think it's i think it's uh
wait where has dodger being this entire
wait where's dodgers that's a good point
yeah i think it's i'm voting i'm voting
i'm voting dodger
i totally forgot dodger was even alive
[Laughter]
it's not me
oh i was getting scared